welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies was that that was
a my skype I was actually going to tell
you that um well you know I um I had a
bit of an accident this weekend I know I
didn't want to you know all right
top of the show huh well all you wanted
a hold on well your load already was hey
let's let's let's go over it I think
it's a pretty work noteworthy it was was
it Friday or Saturday mmm it all blends
together does it I was all blended
Saturday it was Saturday
yeah Saturday um I think we went we went
in the kitchen and we were having
breakfast in the morning and I started I
laughed about the fact that I had farted
and I like farting in the bedroom when
you're sleeping and when you wake up and
you're upset that you woke up from a
farm yeah it's upsetting to me because I
don't that's not the alarm clock of my
cheese yeah because sometimes you'll go
like you'll be out and you'll go great I
was asleep and I just woke up to your
fart and you're like really upset of
course yeah what woman wants to be
awakened by a fart some cool chicks dude
nobody yeah
there's no chicks that like that some
we're done with it so I wasn't next to
you because I was in baby Jane's room
mmm and I went to go take a dump in the
kitchen in the kitchen bathroom down
there right and as I'm in there I'm just
enjoying my time I'm thinking I can
really relax into this dump because dude
I was watching the baby yeah once I can
take a leisurely shit yep and lo and
behold that gets ruined because what
happens is as I'm thinking about the
fact that I want you to hear a fart if I
let it I'm not really paying attention
so on it I feel something in the chamber
yeah I just go aggressive
and when I do bite your bottom lip what
he did that's area I'm sitting on that
stool there's a bar stool in the kitchen
huh and I'm sitting there and I go oh
and then I just feel and there's no
noise
I just feel water coming and I go I just
sharted and you go no you didn't and
then I reach down to touch because I'm
like maybe touched it yeah yeah and it
was just all wet all wet and I go
upstairs and it's just soaked from the
Sun brown yeah I had to wait by the way
I sat in my in my pig stew for a while
because I'd wait for you to come out so
the baby wouldn't be alone well yeah cuz
I was shit I was in the middle of put I
know I'd be charting again like an 80
years old I don't know how to hold in a
fart I know but I didn't thought that I
don't know how to hold in a fart I chose
to let her rip you know push too hard oh
yeah I can I tell you what I think your
fatal flaw was yeah the wooden stool cuz
it's a flat surface
no duh and you were you were sitting on
it fatal flaw is that I had I didn't
have a fart in the chamber I had to dump
a loose like a six I loose meat yeah I
didn't realize what it was when I sat on
that toilet it was it was bombs away
yeah now let me ask you this let's do an
autopsy of your Brown of the yeah shirt
you didn't feel any indication of a six
you didn't feel any cramping or diarrhea
imminent now sometimes I have a real
explosive shit to start the day
depending on depending on the day and
what goes in alright sometimes I don't
but in this case it was like I woke up I
had some coffee and then had some you
know it was scrambled eggs with veggies
but that doesn't make it that formula
doesn't mean it's definitely going to be
loose meat sandwich it could be fine
it's just one of those things where that
day it was just horrendous know what I
think it was hmm I think it was God
punishing you for for wanting me to hear
your fart that's what you told me yeah I
got punished you hmm
he's a vengeful god Old Testament God
hmm gets back at you for that kind of
stuff